andy burnham mayor of greater manchester
with us now hello to you mr burnham
thanks for joining us do you think that
rishi sunak's a socialist
no
certainly not
he's in the newspapers today saying that
he will
govern like margaret thatcher if he's
elected leader margaret thatcher laid
the north of england low when she was in
government so i think we could
confidently say that levelling up will
be uh dead if if he's elected and
continues to uh to to put that kind of
approach
forward so
um i just think we're looking at a
leadership campaign at the moment though
that is a bit farcical as your business
editor said yesterday there are two
major crises facing the country the cost
of living crisis and the nhs crisis with
all ambulance trusts now on black alert
what are these leadership candidates
saying about both of those things that
they're in a comfort zone and they're
not addressing the issues that are right
there in front of the country and this
person will walk into office and have to
deal with from day one so this contest
i'm afraid is not serious at the moment
and all of them need to put aside the
sort of um the gimmicks and the uh and
the jibes of each other and set out how
they will deal with the serious issues
facing the country from day one
um do you have any sympathy for grant
chaps because you've been in that
position haven't you uh where you've
wanted to run and be the leader and it's
not come off it is as i said brutal oh
no i do uh it is
it is a brutal process but that is
politics uh and people are putting
themselves forward to to run the country
so you can expect it to be brutal
because you have to be tested and as i
said i don't think these candidates are
being properly tested the conservative
party has to do a job for the country it
has to make these people say what will
you do day one in office to deal with
the nhs crisis now okay correct me if
i'm wrong but has any of these
candidates talk properly about the nhs
over the last few days i've not heard it
and here we are in the middle of summer
with all ambulance services on black
alert what does that mean for the winter
in the national health service none of
them have anything to say about it so
how can they walk in and be prime
minister in those circumstances they
have to be challenged i think it's
revealing today that
none of the above comes out top when the
public were asked who they want which
suggests it's hardly capturing their
imagination and it even comes joint
second amongst tory members they're
saying uh none of the above you know
they have to seriously raise their game
uh if they are
genuine about wanting to leave this
country in a couple of months time
yeah um we are planning our leadership
debate actually on monday why is it that
politicians
are always uh cautious about doing um
debates
well to me
i mean you reference labour leadership
elections i mean i have had experience
of leadership elections as you say to me
this feels like a party that wants to go
into opposition
it feels as though it's in its comfort
zone playing to the culture war issues
but not actually addressing the things
that are affecting people up and down
the country your viewers k this morning
who are worrying about their finances
who are worrying about the position in
the nhs this party is not dealing with
those issues it's kind of it's in its
own little world talking to itself and
it feels to me as though it's a party
heading into opposition and actually i i
mentioned rishi sunak a moment ago if i
look at the policies of all of them
leveling up will be dead in the water at
the end of this tory leadership campaign
because they are all talking about major
tax cuts at a much smaller state you
can't put that forward and then be
serious about leveling up the country
and leveling up the north of england so
i would say if that is where we end up
at the end of this leadership election
there has to be a general election
because that is a major change on the
from the manifesto on which all of these
people were elected in 2019
mr mayor talk to me about i don't know
if you heard me talking about that young
lad alfie who um went swimming in a
canal
and um drowned um what would you say to
the um
people in uh in the northwest
particularly in greater manchester this
morning because we we hear about these
stories every summer don't we
our
heartbreaking is the only thing i could
could uh
think
really when i saw his picture and you
just imagine what his parents
his family's friends are going through
we've had something similar here uh over
recent times kay there was a young man
who uh sadly died in salford keys uh
last year
when he jumped in after a game of
football so we we know uh what friends
will be going through my shortshare this
morning you know over the last five
years around
just under 50 people uh have died great
monster fire has been called to uh 43
fatalities i think and across the
country i think there were over around
160 deaths last last summer so an even
hottest summer it could it could be
worse here in greater manchester we have
launched uh our cold water campaign uh
and we have been warning about the
dangers from from june actually uh
because it's the shock that can that can
uh cause uh the the the fatality where
people go into even though it's hot
outside people will go into cold water
in a reservoir or in a canal and it's
the shock to the body that causes the
the problem so it's
helpful i guess for me to be able to say
that on your program this morning okay
please look up those campaigns please
promote them amongst family and friends
certainly as we go through the next few
days we need to be very vigilant okay
thank you mr mayor as always much
appreciated thanks very much